Claire is fine, because Rei is here.
After all, Rei and Claire are in the same situation.
Please don't say anything stupid to me, sister. You're just making fun of me. I've told you many times that
I'm serious.  Isn't that what you're
saying? Isn't that just one-sided love for you?
Yes, that's
true. In most cases, I would
choose your sister over you. That's a shame, Ray.
Claire says I'm better than you.
Oh my sister, what's wrong with you, Claire? You'll
believe me when I say I love you.
Of course I doubted your love for me.
Calm down, Ray
Taylor. Count the prime numbers,
sister.
2571131719223137
Claire and Manaria seem to be on good terms. How about some
tea? Ray: That's
not a pot, but a milk pitcher. Excuse me.
What's wrong? I'm pale and suffering from cancer. I
mean, I'm in love with Mr. Hase now.  Is
n't that right, Claire?
[Music]
Yeah.